Today I'm standing.
I live in a city that vibrates with life.
A city of art,
history, science, and projects.
Projects.
I have projects.
To turn them into reality, I need to
get out
and immerse myself in the city.
I need to see, sense,
breathe, connect.
That's what changed my life.
Being able to stand or sit at will,
to stride.
Blend with people.
Wander with my friends.
And talk with them
at eye level.
3 years back,
I met Nicola, who offered, how
would you like to stand up and go for a walk?
At first, I did not believe him.
But
today, I'm standing.
Wow,
what an incredibly inspiring example
of physical AI.
Hi everyone and welcome to AM 117S,
which is all about building physical
AI
with Nvidia on AWS.
I'm Sean Kirby and I'm a principal cloud
architect in our AWS professional
services organization,
and I'm joined today by my colleagues Ali
Shahroni from Nvidia
and Abhishek Shrivasta also from AWS.
We have a fun-filled and packed agenda for
you here today.
I wanted to start off with just a quick survey
show of hands, how many of you already have
physical AI programs underway.
Any folks?
OK, I see a couple of hands there.
Another show of hands, how many people are
considering launching into a physical
AI program in the next 6 months
or so?
OK, some more hands. Well,
we've got something for everyone here today. We're
going to start off with a survey of physical
AI, what it is, and the tremendous
potential
that it offers. We're then going to talk
about what we view as the five key
pillars
for accelerating your physical
AI programs, how to get started and
how to meet some of the challenges that you may be
facing.
We'll talk about a number of proven technologies
from Nvidia on AWS
that will help you with your programs.
We'll then go into
a particular example
where we've used these very architecture
patterns and these technologies to
create a humanoid stockkeeping robot
and we'll include many of the best practices and
lessons learned
that we've gathered along the way.
So first of all,
what is physical AI?
Well, put simply, physical AI
is the embodiment of artificial intelligence
in any physical object or smart
object. Probably most of us
think of robots when we think of physical
AI, and that's certainly one of the greatest
examples.
However,
physical AI extends far beyond
robots to anything in the physical
world, from smart machines
to assembly lines in a factory
to even a whole smart factory or
even a smart municipality
with smart buildings and connected infrastructure
and vehicles. All of these are
part of physical AI systems.
And at the heart of physical AI
is a world foundation model very
similar to the models that have given rise
to so much of the popular generative AI
today.
However, these models
usually incorporate a vast array
of different types of input. They're very multimodal.
So in addition to
some language instruction inputs and maybe
some video or photos for context.
They can take all kinds of other physical
data,
temperature, humidity,
force feedback, sensor data, etc.
and they combine all of that into
an output that then instructs the
physical object
how to behave and to perform sophisticated
behaviors.
The nice thing about these models is that they
incorporate a lot of knowledge about
the physical world
and they generalize very well so
that you can fine tune them to
your particular domains and expect them
to do a variety of tasks.
They're also very good at
adapting quickly to different embodiments,
so different types of humanoids, for example,
doesn't take nearly as much training as
has been invested in the initial world Foundation
model.
And we're going to talk about some examples like
Nvidia, Isaac Groot, for example, and
how to run that in the cloud.
So
what is the impact of all this physical
AI?
Well, one of the key industries I
think that comes to mind when we think about physical
AI
is the manufacturing
and the associated supply chain and logistics,
making and delivering physical goods
throughout the world. There are over
10 million factories,
200,000 warehouses,
1.5 million cars and trucks
that are all part of this complex
industry. And every one of them
stands to benefit
from physical AI.
So the potential is enormous in that
industry, but it extends to all industries
including healthcare, agriculture,
retail, and the public sector and
beyond. Nvidia
CEO Jensen Wong has
stated that 65%
of the global GDP
across industries
can be improved by physical AI.
This is a staggering more than $50
trillion of economic impact.
But physical AI isn't just
some pipe dream out in the future.
Physical AI is here
today. In fact, at Amazon
we're using physical AI in many of our robots
in our warehouses and distribution centers.
Pictured here is Vulcan. This is our first robot
with a sense of touch,
and Vulcan was born out of the desire
to help our stockkeeping workers
to reach both the highest bins on
a rack and the lowest bins as well.
And in order to do so, it needs a multi-sensory,
multimodal input into these foundation
models. It needs to be able to see
where there's space in an existing bin.
And it needs to be able to have
some feedback as it's handling all
different kinds of objects, different shapes
and sizes and textures.
And so we've incorporated a force feedback
mechanism to give it that sense of
touch. All this multimodal data
goes into a physical AI model
that was trained with many of the patterns we're going to
show you here today.
And so now in operation it's
saving our employees up to an hour and
a half a day,
not having to go up and down a ladder and
also making their jobs a lot safer
and more enjoyable as they don't have to bend over
all the time putting a lot of undue stress
on the lower back.
Well, that's not the only place that we're
using physical AI. Another robot
that we use is part of our
Zero Touch manufacturing initiative,
and we're using this robot arm
for the product inspection and auditing
stage for all of our Amazon products.
And of course we're always coming out with new
products, and so
we need to be able to introduce those
products into this zero touch station
without bringing production to a halt.
And so we need to train these robots
to handle these new products in
simulation,
and this is part of our simulation
first initiative, which is a very
important part of the 5 pillars that
we're going to be talking about to really help accelerate
physical AI.
What we do in this case, for example, is we
can bring in a CAD design for
the packaging and for the new product
itself. And then using Nvidia
Cosmos on AWS
batch, we're able to generate
what we do is we generate 50,000
variations of that
CAD
specification so that we can train the robot
through simulation to handle that
new product
and with a zero shot deployment,
that robot is able to handle the new product and
manipulate it as you see here in the animation
without bringing the line down.
That's not the only place we're using AI
here with this robot. We actually also
bring in all of the product specs
and using
Amazon Bedrock behind the scenes
with some large language models,
we interpret those specifications
to understand what kinds of testing
do we need to do on this product, what really
constitutes the necessary
auditing, and so all of that is automated
as we introduce these new products into a
true zero-touch manufacturing
initiative.
Well, what's required fundamentally
to
achieve this kind of physical AI?
We believe there are 5 pillars, and the first
is data.
Training this kind of sophisticated behavior
requires an enormous volume of very
high quality and realistic data.
Some of this data is generated today by
humans through teleoperation and examples
that robots can be trained to emulate,
but the vast majority
will be generated synthetically
in the future because it's just impractical.
The next pillar is around training. It's taking
all of that data, and there are many
applications for training from
fine tuning a world foundation model
to your particular industry or domain
to
training a model through imitation learning or reinforcement
learning and training a policy for
robots to execute particular
advanced and sophisticated tasks.
The next pillar is simulation, and this is
again part of our sim first approach.
We
test these trained models extensively
in a simulated environment before deploying
to the real world. This is both a lot safer
and less time consuming
and less costly as well because we
don't have accidents with
robots and the expensive equipment that
they're ultimately deployed onto.
The fourth pillar is what we call sim
to real, and this is where we have
gone through a cycle of simulation and
training and gotten to a good result. Now
we need to really
test this in the real world. This is
literally where the rubber meets the road,
and as you're developing
more and more sophisticated physical AI,
you're going to be deploying this to more and more different
types of objects, maybe in a manufacturing
setting, different types of machines.
In different locations
around the world and everyone may have a
different version of the model,
a different.
Uh,
type of device and so forth and so managing
your fleet
of physical AI smart devices
becomes a challenge, and we have some technologies
including uh AWS IOT
Greengrass to help you manage this complexity.
The 5th and final pillar is agentic
orchestration,
and this is where we bring together
modular building blocks of physical
AI.
Not only does this provide good separation
of concerns.
But it also provides you with reusable
elements and frankly it's
an essential element to achieve
long running and very sophisticated
behaviors like fulfilling an
order all the way from order placement
to the shipment of that order and all of
the picking and packing and logistical
operations that need to take place in between.
You're going to see how we've used this pillar
in the example of the humanoid
that we built a little bit later on in this talk.
So these 5 pillars are by no
means meant to be part of a waterfall
cascade approach. Once you've been through all the 5,
you're good to go, move on to the next problem.
Instead, they form part of a virtuous
cycle,
a highly iterative process in what we
call the physical AI flywheel.
You start off with your data
and you do some training and then you test
that trained model and simulation,
deploy it to the real world, and then you gain
some feedback from that.
And additional data based on that
real world testing that you can then feed
back into further training and so forth
and so we go around and around the
flywheel loop until we achieve the
level of sophistication and quality
for physical AI that's required.
Now that said, there are still plenty of challenges.
That I'm sure many of you may be thinking about
or are already facing
in this, and we're gonna show you how these Nvidia
technologies
on AWS can help you meet these challenges.
The first is the high volume of data.
In the humanoid example, just the
simple task of
picking a bag of potato chips and putting it
in a box
requires at least 800
examples in order to be able to learn
that through imitation learning.
More sophisticated behaviors could take thousands
or even millions of examples, and
the only way to really achieve that is
through synthetic data generation.
Another challenge is simulation accuracy,
and this really helps to close the sim
to real gap.
You need not only a realistic environment
with photorealistic surroundings and so
forth, but very realistic
physics,
which is a complex topic, and that's something
Nvidia together with AWS can
help you
achieve. Now
all these tools are very sophisticated. They've
got a lot of ingenuity built in and
to really get the most out of them, you really have
to know how to deploy them
most effectively. So
there's some complexity in the setup of this,
and we're going to show you how through things like
Nvidia
NIMs, for example, we can prepackage
that into a distribution that
you can spin up and get working quickly.
Shortcutting all of that complexity.
And that also leads to increased
repeatability and collaboration. You might be facing
some challenges with different teams working
around the world in different standards and so
forth. This is a little bit of a wild west
right now in the physical AI world, but
we'll show you how to standardize this so that you
can share and collaborate more easily.
Then there's time to results. These models
are pretty sophisticated and they
take a very long time to train
on a single instance.
And so you really need to think about multi-GPU
and multi-node parallelization,
and that can be a complex topic.
But here again we're bringing some
proven patterns. We're going to go into more
detail with you here as to how you can get
your multi-node
simulation, your multi-node training
jobs up and running very quickly.
And then of course cost effectiveness trying to
do this on a fleet
of instances yourself
on premise can be very costly and
probably not fully utilized unless you have
a truly massive physical AI
program. So doing this in the cloud gives
you all the benefits of elasticity
and cost effectiveness. And then we talked
about fleet management,
last but not least here, as you begin to
deploy to more and more smart devices, you
need a single pane of glass
to manage these very effectively.
So
Those are the challenges we're going to
be diving deep into each of these pillars
with various solutions for these. You can
see some of them here,
but I want to make sure our colleagues have enough
time to go into the details
and also share this example with you. So
without further ado.
I'm going to pass to
my colleague Ali to take you into
a deep dive in these incredible Nvidia
technologies.
Thank you very much.
Hi all,
uh, I'm Ali Sharoni. I'm a developer relations
manager at Nvidia focusing on the
robotics ecosystem at AWS.
I hope you all agree that we have entered
the era of physical AI.
Autonomous vehicles and
robots have been around for decades,
but something fundamental has recently shifted.
And that's moving from arrays
of
sophisticated
specialized models into a unified
model
that performs end to end
understanding of physical AI.
And one key enabler for that is
what we call the 3 computer
framework.
Let me walk you through this.
So first we need to train a robotic
foundation model
on the cloud using, for example,
the P instances on AWS
that would enable us to develop
large foundation models for robotics
and and use massive scale
data sets to train those.
And then the other computer that we need is for
simulation and synthesis of data that is
used to train those models,
and that's what
You can use like
other like sophisticated
RTX Pro servers on AWS to
synthesize data and train
models and test those on the cloud.
And then the last computer is actually the brain
of the robot that is deployed on the edge,
and for that you can use Ajax computers
and deploy the train models that are optimized
for edge deployment on the cloud.
And those would process real sensory
data on the
uh on the on the edge in real time
and perform actions uh
respectively,
right. So,
But there is a significant data gap when it comes
to physical AI.
Unlike large language models that can
leverage
internet scale data,
robotic systems face severe data scarcity.
We need thousands of human demonstrations, as
Sean mentioned,
to train a simple manipulation
task, and that does not scale
and it's not,
it's not feasible.
So what we can use is instead
to use a
handful of real data
and to augment those using synthetic data
to generate diverse and
um
and edge cases for, for robotic
training. So
you can use total operation
to collect the initial seed of training
data using
manual demonstrations,
and then you can use Isaac SIM
and Isaac Lab to
generate variations of those using
realistic scenarios,
realistic trajectories,
and add variations of the scene.
Guru Guruth mimic from Isaac
family of models can actually be used
to
create those trajectories for you, and Isaac's
team would add the variations to the scene.
So what we are delivering here is
quite simple. We are using
real world data.
And
augmenting those by adding
domain randomization into the scene.
So let's dive deeper into this.
This is
the data that you need for training real
realistic physical AI
applications. At the top we have real world data
that is high quality
but it's hard to capture and it's not scalable.
But then you have synthetic data
that is not as high quality as
real data
because it doesn't capture a lot of the nuances
of physical interactions and dynamics,
uh, but it's very scalable.
But at the bottom you have
in level data
which is not really usable for robotics
applications. For example,
if you have a video of someone picking up an object,
it doesn't give you the tactile feedback or
the force dynamics
or the mechanical
interactions that you need to train a robot.
So we need a hybrid approach here
that would take a small
amount of real world data
and would amplify it and diversify
it using domain randomization
and real physics simulation.
Right, so you can leverage Cosmos
Family Awards Foundation models to bridge
that data gap.
Uh, this is an open source set of models,
uh, from Nvidia
that is available on AWS and, uh,
and on GitHub,
and, uh.
In those family of models we have Cosmos Predict
that allows you to generate up to 30 seconds
of video
that would describe what happens next.
And we also have cosmos transfer that
would allow you to generate photorealistic
scenarios by varying lighting
conditions, background,
the environment, and and the weather, etc.
And we also have Cosmos Reason, which is a visual
language model
that is trained for physical interactions
and it can support human-like thinking.
Here is an example of leveraging
cosmos transfer in combination with
Isaac Simon and Nvidia Omniverse.
Nvidia Omniverse provides you the physical accuracy
of the real world,
the physics part of it, the simulation of the robot
and the 3D assets and the interaction
that happens between those.
But then you can leverage cosmos
cosmos transfer to
inject diversity and domain randomization
into the scene and create very realistic
scenes that would help you amplify your
training data set for your robotics
applications. Another
way to create synthetic data
is to use dreams.
This is Group Dreams from AI that would
allow you to use a single image and a
text prompt.
To generate robotics trajectories
that would be then used to
train your physical AI models.
So you can just provide a simple text prompt.
And
use Cosmos
predict
to create
a future scenario based on
based on your text prompt and single image input,
and then use Cosmos
reason to label the data
and create the trajectories that you need and validate
validate those as well.
Right, so let's take a look at
the end to end pipeline for
a ste-first approach for physical AI
development. So on
the left you have your training data,
and that can be
text, image, videos, teleop
data, or simulation data.
And then you have at the top you have your
foundation model training pipeline where
you have a model architecture and
you train those and validate it and optimize
it for deployment.
And that's your perception model.
But for robotics application of physical AI,
you also need,
you need the robot to interact with the physical world. So
just the perception is not good enough.
So at the bottom, that's what you have robot learning,
and that's where you train the model in
simulation
using
the perception model as well as your synthetic training
data to train the policies
that would allow the robot to interact with the physical
world. But that's not a single
shot training. This actually
works as a virtual cycle where
the VLA would then use the demonstrations
from the robot to improve itself
and then it's fed back to the loop,
and that's how the robot
would be trained and the VLA would be trained together
to meet the KPIs for deployment.
And finally, you can also test and validate all of
that in simulation as well.
So you can have your, your test data as
well in simulation
and as a fleet, not a
single unit,
and test the whole pipeline.
So the whole thing,
the amazing thing about this is that you do
the entire robot
training and the perception training
in simulation without
doing anything in the real world that would save you a
lot of time and money in terms
of prototyping and testing
on real hardware.
Right, so just double clicking on the
learning part and the training parts, you
can, uh, for the robot for the robotics
part of it,
you can uh
use different types of data
together with Isaac Lab
for their enforcement learning or imitation
learning. And uh
And then you can use Isaacs and Cosmos for
synthetic data generation and software
testing in the loop.
And while that cycle is
done and your model is trained, you can then deploy
that to the edge on jets on tour
for various applications like humanoid manipulation
or autonomous mobile robots.
For humans, humanoids specifically, you
can leverage the generalized humanoid robot
model from Nvidia Groot N 1.5,
that is an open source model and is available
on hugging face and on AWS
that would enable a two-system architecture
for thinking fast and slow. The System
2 is for reasoning and
understanding, and System One is for fast thinking
and fast reactions.
And it also supports cross embodiments.
Once you have generated all your
synthetic data
and trained your robot policies
and perception models,
you, you're now ready to deploy
the robot to the edge,
and for that
you're going to need also a very performant
ultra high
computer to be able to do
interactions with the real world and fleet management.
So Thor is a good candidate for that. And
here are some of the
early customers that we have engaged with.
So it can be used for human aid robots,
for multimodal
AI and perception interactions.
You can use it for visual agents, which allows
you to
generate custom alerts and video summarizations
in warehouse environments, for example.
For mobile medical robotics and instrumentation
where you need real-time
streaming and inference,
Thor, it provides great compute
power for that with over
2000 tops of compute.
And also for autonomous robots and
machines where you need simultaneous localization
and mapping
or navigation for agriculture, for example,
Tor is a great
computer for those
and for high performance computing
and inference where you need high bandwidth
and high quality images, again, Tor
has great audio throughput for
those applications.
And with that, I'm going to pass it to my colleague
Abhi Shaikh who is going to talk to you,
talk you through
some great use cases for
humanoid robotics. Thank you.
Thanks, Ollie.
Good morning everybody. I hope you enjoyed
the session thus far.
I'm Abhishek Shrivastov, principal solutions
architect AWS.
For the remaining of the presentation,
I'm going to go through the exciting
collaboration between Nvidia and
AWS
in advancing the physical AI.
But before I go deeper,
I would like to bring the same slide
once again.
This is what
a complete ecosystem
looks like.
5 pillars of physical AI.
Data,
training,
simulation,
semurial,
and agentic orchestration.
And across each of them,
Nvidia and AWS
is offering a unified
solution
for our customers.
Keep this pillars in mind.
As I move forward,
I'll cover the integration architecture,
as well as the making of a
humanoid robot
for a supply chain operation.
So let's start with a data pillar,
the foundation of physical AI.
Training a humanoid require humanoid robot.
Requires a massive amount
of synthetic data,
and as we learn,
capturing the data from a real world
is really time and
a resource intensive.
This is where Nvidia Cosmo's World
Foundation model on AWS
can help our customers.
So when we are making
a humanoid robot for our demo,
we followed a three-step
process. In
step one,
we captured 800
episodes of
human tele-operated data.
Performing a pick and place
operation in the real world
for a single environment.
This is the ground truth, and
it sets the baseline
of how a successful operation
looks like in a real world.
We then use that data,
the human tele-operated data,
to train Cosmos Predict World
Foundation model on AWS
batch at scale.
Using this fine-tuned Cosmos
Predict World Foundation model,
we augmented the data sets
to create a future world
state. Of the videos.
And that completes
how a new synthetic data looks
like in the physical world.
In the 2nd step,
we augmented the dataset
using cosmos transfer to
create diversity
such as material
and lighting conditions.
We then use cosmos transfer
in the final step
to evaluate
and filter
the synthetic data that is generated.
Just so you know,
with the 16 hours of
human demonstration,
we have created more than 1000 scenarios
of synthetic data
that would have taken for us almost
4 months
to train the humanoid robot
for the supply chain operations.
So let's go deeper and learn about
the deployment architecture
in AWS.
We have chosen
Amazon EKS.
To deploy,
which is a fully managed Kuberniity service
to deploy Cosmos Predict
foundation model on AWS.
EKS scales across multiple
node
based on the inference volume
while still managing the control plane availability.
One of the key benefits of this architecture
is total cost of ownership optimization,
the TCO optimization.
NIMMS containers are
pre pre-optimized for
high inference volumes,
whereas EKS
offers a dynamic scaling
and pay as you go model that is required
for the optimum compute utilization
and reduce overall cost of training.
For our human demonstration, we have used
P54X Large EC2
instance, each of them powered
by Nvidia H100 tensor
core GPU
with 256
GBytes of system memory
and 80 gigabyte of
GPU memory, just sufficient
to run Cosmos Predict on
AWS.
We are leveraging Amazon Elastic
File System EFS
to store the generated
synthetic data out of Cosmos
model. And cloud watch
to monitor the cluster
performance as well as the job
inference attributes.
If you'd like to go deeper into learning
how to deploy
Nvidia Cosmos models on AWS,
I would highly encourage you to check out
our detailed blog post.
Let's dive into the training pillar
of physical AI.
This is where
you teach the policy
to interact with the physical world.
There are 2 key approaches
when it comes to training a robot.
Reinforcement learning
and imitation learning.
Reinforcement learning is like training
by examples,
sorry, training by trial and errors.
Imagine a humanoid robot walking
in a complex environment.
Each time
The robot takes a stable step
forward.
You give a positive reward, and
when it stumbles,
you provide a negative feedback.
This approach is extremely
important when it comes to introducing an
adaptive behavior
within a robot like locomotion policy.
On the other hand,
the imitation learning
is like teaching by an example.
So as a human, you demonstrate
an example
and the robot is going to observe
the demonstration and imitate
the movement.
This type, the imitation learning,
is very effective when it comes
to
performing a manipulative task like
pick and place operations.
But in practice, when you are building a
complex physical AI system,
we normally use a combination of
both reinforcement learning
as well as imitation learning.
Now let's explore the
architecture
for training
pipeline on AWS.
We have made this really simple for
our, for our customer.
So we have a common architecture
to run Nvidia Isaac Lab
for reinforcement learning.
And Nvidia Groot N1
Open Foundation model
on AWS for imitation
learning use cases.
At the center of this architecture, what you
see here is AWS Batch,
which orchestrates the training
as well as the fine tuning across
distributed compute resources.
Batch is a fully managed serverless
batch subservice that offers
a pay as you go operating model
which is really effective
for your cost optimized training
on cloud.
Using
Amazon Elastic container Service,
you can deploy Isaac Lab
or Nvidia Groot
containers
across multiple node and multiple GPU
at scale.
Amazon EFS
serves as a persistent storage
across distributed node
for storing the checkpoints of
training policy.
And finally, Cloudwatch
provides a real-time monitoring
of
training jobs
like loss curves and learning
rates.
For more details,
you can follow the step by step guide
of running Nvidia Isaac Lab
on AWS in the QR code.
Let's talk about simulation pillar,
a critical component
of validating a trained
policy in a virtual environment.
Simulation provides a virtual
environment
to validate a robot behavior
before you deploy them
in a real world.
We can test thousands of scenarios
in parallel with the different lighting
and material conditions,
object object placement,
as well as including some of the
edge cases, which is really
hard and impractical to replicate
in real world scenarios.
This is where Nvidia Isaac SIM
on Amazon EC2
helps our customers
to deploy simulation environment
quickly on AWS.
Isaac Sim is a physically accurate,
photorealistic simulation platform
built on Nvidia Omnivores.
You can simulate physical world dynamics
such as friction,
gravity,
collision, etc.
A great example of a simulation
is training
our own humanoid robot
in a virtual AWS Expo floor
with thousands of virtual attendees,
different carpet and flooring
conditions to ensure it works
before we brought them in to reinvent.
And like that, you can simulate
various various environments
such as warehouse,
factory floors,
healthcare facilities, and many more.
Now traditionally,
running Isaac SIM
requires high-end RTX workstations
on-premise.
It is hard to set up
and it is constrained by the physical
capacity
of your
physical server.
We made Nvidia Isaac's same deployment
on AWS
really simple for our customers.
AWS Marketplace
offers a fully configured EMI
to run Nvidia Isaac SIM workstation
for both Windows and Linux
environment.
You can deploy Isaac SIM
in a few clicks
over a 100s of EC2
environments powered by Nvidia GPUs,
so you can get started
to validate within a few hours,
then a few weeks.
Let's discuss sim to real.
Now here is the reality.
Sometimes the model
that works in simulation
does not effectively perform
in the real world,
and this is called reality gap.
Different factors such as physics
accuracies, sensors, noise,
as well as the environment variations.
Can impact the performance of a
policy in the real world.
Closing this reality gap
is an ongoing science
that requires you to bring
in a human feedback
in the training loop.
With every iteration, you
need to transfer the model from cloud
to edge devices,
manage the deployment fleet,
and as well as over the air deployment
and updates.
This is where AWS IOT
services can help our customers
to manage the communications and
handle the deployment from cloud
to physical robot.
So let's explore the architecture.
AWS IOT
core Service offers an edge
to cloud communication hub.
IoT Core establishes a secure
bi-directional communication to
offer a command back to your robot,
as well as the telemetry
data back to the cloud.
Amazon's Sage Maker model registry
offers you
a centralized repository
to store
version
and manage the physical AI
models.
And AWS IOT Greengrass V2
facilitate the model
and component deployment to the Edge
devices.
For more details, please do check out
our blog to deploy robot
using IoT Greengrass V2.
Let's discuss the final
pillar, which is the most exciting
one, agentic orchestration.
Which transform a
robot to handle the intelligent
generic task.
Physical AI evolved from a
specialized
to a generalist robot.
A specialized robot follow a rule-based
logic.
But the generalist,
like humanoid,
requires cognitive reasoning ability
to respond and operate
in a dynamic environment.
This things like goal
understanding, path planning, task
decompositions,
each of them
are really complex tasks
to process.
But using
Amazon Bedrock Agent Core,
customers can build these atomic
AI agent
at scale for a physical AI
system.
Let's dive into the architecture diagram
for agentic orchestration.
At the core of this architecture, we
have Amazon Bedrock Agent Core
to for building, deploying,
and operating
the AI agents at scale.
Bedrock Agent Core
can help
to build a modular AI agents
for functions such as inventory
planning,
task decompositions,
path planning, and SKU
identification, and many more.
For the humanoid robot that you will see
in a few minutes,
we have used the
Bedrock agent core
with a fine-tuned NOAA
Light Foundation model
to do a task validation.
So every time the robot
picks an item from the table,
we validate if the
operation is successful, otherwise
provide a dynamic signal for the next step.
The architecture is fully
scalable
from a single robot to a
wide fleet automation.
Bedrock Agent Core provides
an intelligent layer
that transforms a physical
automation
to a physical AI.
Let me walk you through the top 5
reasons why you should be choosing
AWS and Nvidia for
your physical AI journey.
First,
scalable infrastructure.
Physical AI development
requires a scalable infrastructure
for both training
as well as simulation.
The training that used to take
weeks
now takes hours
using AWS infrastructure.
Second,
a complete physical AI ecosystem.
Nvidia and AWS have fundamentally
changed
and reshaped the stages of
physical AI development
from the data curation
to the model training
to a photorealistic simulation and
agentic orchestration. Across
each of this pillar, we are offering
a unified solution across
all industries.
Third,
optimized economics.
Frugality is the core principle
of a well architected solutions.
Traditional physical AI developments
require a large investment of
GPU cluster on-premise.
With AWS pay as you go model
and various savings plans, customers
can easily save
cost of training simulation
at scale on cloud.
Fourth,
robust security and compliance.
When you are deploying a physical AI
system for a healthcare facility,
manufacturing plant, or a public
space,
security is foundational.
AWS offers an enterprise
grade security for you
to build an end to end encryption,
role-based security model, granular
access control to offer a
secure and compliant
physical AI systems.
And finally,
unified edge to cloud
architecture.
We can train a sophisticated model
on AWS and seamlessly
deploy on Nvidia jets and devices.
AWS IT services
is really closing the gap
between cloud and edge infrastructure.
I hope you are excited to see a
short demo of our humanoid robot
fully developed
using Nvidia Physical AI stack
on AWS.
Welcome to
our AWS Gen AI lab
at HQ2 in Arlington,
Virginia.
We are buying
an item from a fake website.
As soon as the order is placed, the
control plane agent
receives the signal
and triggers
multiple AI agents
that perform different tasks such
as path planning
and inventory search.
Ladies and gentlemen, welcome
our humanoid robot
Storm.
The fine-tuned Groot
N 1.5 model
is running on Nvidia G6
EC2 offering,
providing a vision language action
model to perform pick and place
tasks.
This is the place where we are running the task
validation.
Once the task validation is
successful, we identify the
nearest delivery workstations,
the empty container,
and drop
the item
in the box.
I hope this demo inspired you to
build your next physical AI
system.
Please do check out our AWS
guidelines, including the complete
reference architecture
for building a physical AI with Nvidia
and AWS.
Join us this afternoon if you, if you'd like to
go hands on on our session IND
for physical AI for building a physical AI
with Nvidia and AWS.
Hope you enjoyed our session.
We have a humanoid demonstration in this room,
so feel free to engage and ask.